we've never seen such details underwater
pictures before four years locals
thought basking sharks were monsters but
today we can reveal the secrets of the
UK's largest and most elusive fish it's
early morning on the Isle of Mull off
the northwest coast of Scotland basking
sharks come here every summer marine
scientists want to know whine
for several years we've been gathering
information about how they move where
they go in the winter when they come
back to Scotland but we've never really
understood whether they find mates
whether they're eating how they might
socialize with other individuals basking
sharks can be spotted on the water's
surface where they feed on microscopic
organisms put plankton they can grow up
to nine metres long and for years they
were hunted for their liver oil now in
the UK at least they are a protected
species and we soon spot not just one
but several
and have this close encounter with a 9
meter long female
it's incredible that we've seen so many
basking sharks here today when it was
feared for many years they'd been hunted
almost to extinction in this part of
Scotland but the challenge for the team
today isn't to understand what happens
when the Sharks break the surface but to
know what they do when they disappear
underneath to do that the team tag the
shark with a beacon that will be
followed by this autonomous underwater
robot that's talking to us right now you
hear that so it's basically sending out
a message to us and it would be telling
us its speed its direction it would also
be telling us really cool information
about the shark that its tracking this
is unparalleled technology that reveals
the sharks underwater behavior for the
very first time we can see they skimmed
the ocean floor they feed and they show
signs of courtship they might be using
the area for breeding in which case it
would be really a really important area
for basking sharks and an area that we
need to protect and this area is within
a proposed marine protected area that's
out to consultation with the Scottish
government
it used to be easier to see basking
sharks around the UK but sightings
further south have become rarer and
protecting an area where they breed
could be more important than ever for
this gentle giant of the sea cat who
never taught sea sky news of the Isle of
Mull